Now that we know how we're able to store information, it's time to turn to the
next crucial part in the study of memory. And that's our ability to retrieve
the information that we've stored. So retrieval is our ability to recall
information that's previously been stored in our memories. Remember we talked
about two different types of memory, Explicit and Implicit. And with Implicit
memory we can recall something without consciously trying to do so. I like to
tell my students an example of me trying to learn how to knit. I looked at
books and tried and tried to follow their examples to no avail. So I ended up
taking a lesson, and I had a teacher who showed me how to hold the knitting
needles. How to hold the yarn, and more importantly, how to wrap it around such
that I can make a knitted stitch. So I practiced and practiced my knitting and
I made several scarves. And then summer came and I put my knitting away. Now as
Christmas got closer, I thought it'd be really nice if I could knit each of my
nieces a scarf. And then I realized, I'd forgotten all the rules my teacher
taught me. But I did remember what I know about memory. And so I thought, just
maybe, if I pick up those knitting needles, my hands will remember what to do.
And that's exactly what happened. I picked up my needles and I started
knitting. So this is a good example of implicit memory, and more importantly,
procedural memory.